good morning Hank it's Monday January
18th which means you know any day now
today we're going to talk about
fatherhood because that's all I'm
thinking about
so Inc obviously I'm very excited about
the prospect of being a father but to be
totally honest sometimes I think that
I'm not entirely qualified for example I
don't even remember to shave every day
also I'm pretty lazy not in the sense
that I don't work hard but in the sense
that I don't move much also our father
is a really awesome father like he's
done a great job and he's always been
proud of us and supportive Andy's made
tons of sacrifices for us and he can do
all that dad stuff like woodworking I'm
not a good woodworker it's a hard
example to live up to but on the other
hand I'm lucky to even have that example
the other thing about our dad Hank is
that dad can always answer those
questions that kids have about the
nature of the world like why is the sky
blue
whereas I cannot answer those questions
even though dad has explained it to me
like a thousand times so in my kid asks
that I'm either gonna have to say I
don't understand it it's very
complicated called grandpa or I'm gonna
say the sky is blue because in space
there are these gigantic blue birds like
pterodactyls and they poop blue and
cover the atmosphere with blue except
when they're sick when they poop gray
and that's why clouds are gray there's
going to be a terrible science student
because he's gonna believe deep down
that there are these birds orbiting the
world whose poop affects the color of
our sky and I will be a failure
but Hank deep down I think the nature of
impending fatherhood is that you are
doing something you're unqualified to do
and then you become qualified while
doing it which is in some ways analogous
to writing and publishing a novel
although in this case the novel is a
person who will grow up and if you mess
up will require a lot of expensive
therapy
that's the sound that my anxiety makes
but anyway Hank whenever I start to feel
anxious about impending fatherhood I
remind myself of one important fact I am
NOT the first organism ever to face
parenthood and many of them have been
much less qualified than I am I mean
Hank right now Willie could have like
seven kids thank you for the licks I
mean if we hadn't cut his balls off and
Hank I think we can agree that Willie
while he is in arguably adorable is not
well qualified
be a dad for one thing he's an idiot hey
Willie what's the square root of 4 what
do you have to multiply times itself to
get 4 ah this no the answer is not Lix
the answer is 2 so I'll be ok although I
do need to start shaving more and Hank
I'm comforted by the knowledge that even
though my baby might have a doofus for a
father he's gonna have an awesome mom
and an awesome uncle Hank and Aunt
Catherine hank dftba I'll see you on
Wednesday
oh and sometime if you can I'd love it
if you made a video for me that answers
all those questions that kids ask you
know why is water wet why do platypi lay
eggs why is the sky blue so that after
the baby is you know born and reaches
the age of curiosity I won't look like
an idiot